one of the most embarrassing and
pathetic press briefings of the Trump
presidency so far took place yesterday
and that means a lot I mean we had six
months of Sean Spicer after all
Sarah Huckabee Sanders who I guess is
trying to go by Sarah Sanders now but
I'm not doing it I'm calling her Sarah
Huckabee Sanders for the foreseeable
future I find her to be arguably the
most vile character in this entire
administration probably alongside
Sebastian Gorka who is out now and Jared
Kushner Trump's son-in-law in terms of
just my my feeling repelled in in this
sort of visceral way Sarah Huckabee
Sanders is at the top of the list and
she really outdid herself yesterday I
watched her press briefing where she had
to field question after question about
the indictment of Paul Manafort the
indictment of gates the guilty plea of
George papadopolis and she was spinning
so bad I was wondering whether she was
having some kind of a medical incident
maybe a seizure of stroke of some kind
because she was making no sense
whatsoever and right at the beginning
jumping directly into talking point
number one for the Trump cronies a
rounding surrounding these indictments
which is hey the real issue here is
Hillary Clinton but look today's
announcement has nothing to do with the
president has nothing to do with the
president's campaign or campaign
activity the real collusion scandal is
we've said several times before has
everything to do with the Clinton
campaign fusion GPS and Russia there's
clear evidence of the Clinton campaign
colluding with Russian intelligence to
spread disinformation and smear the
president to influence election we've
been saying from day one there's been no
evidence of Trump Russia collusion and
nothing in the indictment today changes
that at all the campaign
these was definitely about the campaign
it has nothing to do with the activities
of the campaign it has to do with his
failure to tell the truth that doesn't
have anything to do with the campaign or
the campaign tactic Oh Sarah the issue
is not Hillary Clinton only the most
disconnected from reality ideologically
committed trumpets could still believe
that the real issue here is Hillary
Clinton and next being asked more
specifically about George papadopolis
what volunteer
he never was really involved who was he
nobody knows this guy is a mystery to
everybody he used to explain when George
papadopolis roll with the campaign it
was extremely limited it was a volunteer
position and again no activity was ever
done in an official capacity on behalf
of the campaign and never going what
about the outreach to these making the
campaign officials try to put together
this you mean the outreach that was what
happened with his outreach he reached
out and nothing happened beyond that
which I think shows one his level of
importance in the campaign and two shows
what little role he had with in
coordinating anything officially for the
campaign I love it he did outreach but
nobody reached back out to him now Trump
of course has the best people around him
but he had a guy who was completely
incompetent the guy was doing outreach
and nothing came of it apparently
because he's not one of these really
fine people that Trump put around him
and then Sarah Huckabee Sanders asked
about so you know Trump said that this
entire robert muller thing was a hoax
and you said that it's wrapping up
what's going on with it and sarah
huckabee sanders doesn't answer whether
trump still believes the investigation
is a hoax but insists it's almost over
investigation the president at times is
calling
a hoax and he's called it a witch hunt
use similar type of language before it
relates to his investigation last week
you indicated Sara that you believe that
mr. Muller is wrapping up his
investigation and I've heard similar
things coming from others senior
administration officials do you still
believe that mr. Muller is in the
process of wrapping up his investigation
we still expect this to conclude soon
yeah they expect it to wrap up just any
day now I hope she's not holding her
breath these are the same talking points
from the people who used to say there
would never be charges and there was a
really good follow-up I'm sort of
skipping ahead then we'll go back later
during this abortion of the press
briefing there was a follow-up asking
her well what makes you think this is
almost over and listen to the answer
that she gives what leads you to believe
that this will conclude from the MOE
investigation have you been giving given
a heads up what those are the
indications that we have at this time I
still attend that we believe that it
will be concluded soon but beyond that I
don't have anything else to add on a
specific time frame well I'm convinced
and now then we get back into the George
papadopolis stuff what about the fact
that he's in a picture with Donald Trump
at the table along with Jeff Sessions
clearly a meeting going on that is not a
meeting with just random volunteers that
have no significance whatsoever also
citing that Trump said this is one of my
foreign policy advisors he was in praat
in contact with people promising Hillary
Clinton dirt what about that Sarah there
how can you describe Papadopoulos as
having a limited role when there
there's a photograph of mr. Papadopoulos
sitting at a table with millions of
people so he was also cited by
then-candidate Trump in a meeting with
the Washington Post as to who is top
foreign policy advisers are that seems
to fight against what we're saying and
also how is it not collusion when george
papadapolis is in contact with various
people who are promising dirt on Hillary
Clinton I a series of events that
closely mirrors what occurred with the
president's own son this individual was
on a pursuit of information and that was
damaging about the Clintons how is all
of that not collusion look this
individual was the member of a volunteer
advisory council that at one time over
the course of a year and he was part of
a list that was read out in the
Washington Post I'd hardly call that
some sort of regular adviser or as you
want to you know push that he's like a
senior member of the staff it's he was
not paid by the campaign he was a
volunteer on a again a council that
meant once what don't you understand no
one knew the guy no one saw the guy he
was a nobody and then major Garrett asks
a good one which is she keeps saying and
you heard her say there this guy was a
volunteer volunteer implies he showed up
to do get-out-the-vote calls by logging
into some phone banking system from home
right he was a volunteer in the sense
that he s wasn't paid but that suggests
he just showed up you don't just show up
and are placed at a table with donald
trump and jeff sessions to talk about
policy and she just spins into oblivion
we have the terminology spam you say
george papadapolis head
official capacity what do you mean by
that I mean he was a volunteer on the
campaign and a volunteer member of an
advisory council that met one time so
these activities were entirely of his
invention no one asked him to do any of
these things is that what you're telling
the American public I'm telling you that
he was a volunteer member of a hint an
advisory council that literally meant
one time that just means he wasn't paid
the fact that you're not paid doesn't
mean you're not directly involved with
high-level discussions in a campaign
it's not an answer and then Sarah
Huckabee Sanders is asked well how did
Donald Trump react when he heard the
news of these indictments on Muller
you've spoken with the president today
yes can you give us a little bit about
his reaction to the news this morning
obviously news that swept the nation's
capital but what how did the president
respond to this news about two people
who did work for his campaign was he
disappointed that Paul Manafort received
this news today that he was being
charged on these 12 counts he responded
the same way the rest of us in the White
House have and that's without a lot of
reaction because it doesn't have
anything to do with us she wants us to
believe that when the White House heard
that Trump's campaign manager was being
charged with 12 crowns of counts of
criminal activity they were super calm
calm as cucumbers we didn't really have
much of a reaction because it has
nothing to do with us let's move on to
the the transgender military ban or
something like that no one believes this
and in fact numerous reports say that
Trump has been absolutely seething since
the release of these indictments
he's been glued to big-screen TVs
watching what all the TV networks are
reporting on even the Trump
administration isn't so naive that
they'd think that this is no big deal
and then starting to wrap up the
questioning here asked about hey you
know Trump says that he would hire the
best people but he seems to be hiring
terrible people does this tell us
anything about Trump's ability to hire
the best people but doesn't it speak to
the president's judgment anyone choose
to have these two individuals and very
high positions having allegedly
committed these crimes in the years
leading up to their role these were
seasoned operatives not you make it
sound like they were you know regular
offenders that have been
in in massive amounts of trouble these
were seasoned operas that worked on a
number of campaigns Paul Manafort was
brought in to lead the delegate process
which he did and was dismissed not too
long after that no regrets no answer no
answer about what this says about
Trump's hiring skills because of course
they're terrible even though they're one
of the things Trump has run on and
lastly another direct question about
what about Trump hiring the best people
the two people who work for the
president are now under indictment one
is pleaded guilty and he promised to
hire only the best people look again
this goes back to these were activities
that took place outside of the scope of
the campaign I can't comment on anything
they did whatever these are the best
people to hide look the president hired
Paul Manta for two handed to handle the
delegate process which he did and he was
dismissed not too long after that
sixty-five lies Seth abran Sabra
Abramson attorney Jeff Seth Abramson
outlined the full list of 65 lies that
sarah huckabee sanders told during a
twenty-something minute press briefing
we're showing you just a couple tweets
from Seth Abramson with the first
handful or so of Lies 65 lies in 20 plus
minutes without a single actual
substantive answer about anything
throughout the entire press briefing you
tell me how well things are going in the
Trump White House right now